from absolutely nothing to finished
product
including renders in under 15 minutes
let's see if we can do it
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me i am a registered
architect in the state of western
australia
today we are looking at creating and
designing
something from scratch on archicad 24.
i'm going to be taking you through the
process of starting out setting up your
templates and all your views
taking it into twin motion and exporting
it that's the goal at least
let's see what we can achieve okay so
we've opened up archicad 24 with the
australian standard template
whatever template you open up is
probably going to be the same as what i
see here in front of me
if you don't see these side panels here
on the right hand side you can easily go
to window
palettes and open up your trace and
reference which is the top right hand
one
and the navigator which is the bottom
one that you see
so to start off a project we always want
to start by pressing command 7 which
opens up the story settings it's either
control or command depending on what
system you're working on we want to
start up by inserting one below and
creating a footings layer
which needs to be roughly -172 below the
ground
it gives you the thickness of the slab
ground can be three meters for the
purpose of the argument
first can be another three meters but
what you want to do is
insert another story and go ground
ceiling
and give that potentially about 300 mil
and then
do the same for the roof and all you
want to do is click ok here
if we start with a slab on the right
hand side
you can click the slab tool and you can
draw a very simple slab you click once
and it will start dragging the second
time you click it'll finish that slab
what we want to do is actually delete
that click the slab tool
click it once and type so maybe we want
to make this project
20 meters by 6 meters
and we have our first slab if we want to
show everything in 3d it's
up here but if you ever accidentally
close that tab you can right click
and show all in 3d so
there we have it we have our first slab
which you can orientate and orbit around
by holding shift and the center scroll
wheel
so we have our slab if we wanted to
change the material of that slab we can
click
command t to open up the slab section
materiality palette
or you can click this little icon here
if we click that it opens up the dialog
and we can either do a generic roof slab
change elements through that or we can
simply
change the material of it if we click
link all
it automatically links everything in
that section
let's say we want that slab to be
concrete so we're going to try to find a
concrete there we go on the right hand
side we have concrete concrete let's go
concrete light 23 for the purposes of
the argument
and there we go it automatically changes
the look and feel of
that slab now these textures are
important later on when we move the twin
motion because twin motion
links all of your textures that you have
used that are identical so if you go and
place concrete on a wall that you want
to be a different texture
it's automatically going to join those
two and you're not going to be able to
differentiate them
so we want to make sure we get textures
right moving back to the ground floor
plan we're going to use our first wall
tool
what you're going to see is everything
comes with layers
layers are important because you can
change layers how you want so you can
have different views for different
things
this is an external wall for the
purposes of this so it can stay on
external wall the type of wall in itself
we can start with the outside face
which is demonstrated like that and if
you want to flip it you can just do the
p button
or you can click the little rotate
button there
so we can do the outside face we can do
the center line
or we can do the inside face depending
on how you want to draw that wall
for argument's sake we're going to do
outside face and we have a standard
selection automatically generated of
different
concrete wall types brick types timber
types steel
types whatever so for the purposes of
this
let's go
90 mil stud partition that way we can do
a 90 mil
perimeter wall there we go if we click
back on our 3d
that's automatically generated straight
away but you can see
it is a wrong concrete texture so if we
click that command t
again click all those this is the
outside face
this is the corners and this is the
internal face
so let's say we want to change the
outside face to some sort of
steel roof material because we're going
to make
almost container like projects so we're
going to go corrugated sheet metal for
the outside
for the inside we want to make plaster
we want to make it look nice
white haven here which gives us a color
option it doesn't matter what color
options you have
you can paint it whatever you like it's
completely up to you oh sorry that was
the actual edges so that needs to be
also the corrugated roof sheeting
and the last one needs to be the paint
so if we click ok we will see that the
outside has
changed to this steel corrugated look
and the inside is our painted plaster
so if we go back to our ground floor
plan at the top here
we can jump up to our ground ceiling and
we see nothing
now that might be an issue for you if
you're trying to understand what's going
on the floor below
or any floor for that matter what you
can do is right click on the story
that you want to see and click show as
trace reference
and now everything that you've shown on
the ground floor plan is shown
on that new plan that you're looking at
if we're going to design a ceiling let's
say we go back to that slab tool
which is this one here and we're going
to change
those settings we're going to change
that generic slab
to this icon here without the
compositions across so it's a basic
composition
we're going to make it 10 mil thick it
automatically knows it's plasterboard
it's 3000 above that floor level because
that's what we set up our stories
originally
and whilst we're here we might already
just paint that all the right color so
we'll paint that titanium white to
differentiate the ceilings
and the floor so we click ok and we're
able
to join automatically clicks
and creates so there we go we have our
first
box that isn't very exciting but we'll
keep going
so what we also want to do is include a
new slab so let's say we go back to the
slab tool
and we want to have so we want to have a
300mm thick slab
we don't want it to be plasterboard we
actually want it to be concrete so we
find where the structural concrete is
click on that change that back to the
concrete that we used before
concrete light 23 and what we actually
want to do is we want to zoom
in to the corners and find
where the plasterboard separates from
the wall material so
we can run our sheet beyond so if we go
back to here
click it on the internal and create that
slab
and then go back into 3d you'll find
that it's just hovering and doing
this problematic image now what we want
to do
is we can come down to our little man
down the bottom click explore
and use the joystick to play like a
video game so w
s a d and c and space bar help you move
around
so what we want to do is actually fly
into the house click on that slab
up here move it up 300 mil so now we can
see the plaster sitting underneath that
concrete slab
we can see the concrete slab above and
the reason we did it 10 mil
offset is so we can click on this wall
here
and ungroup it so what you want to do is
click alt g
and then you have this stretch height
ability
we have to ungroup it because if it
isn't ungrouped it won't let you stretch
it
so we can stretch it past there and then
we can continue
to stretch it past the footing so the
footing isn't seen
but what we didn't do with the footing
is articulate that 10 mil offset so if
we click on that layer again
i work a lot in 3d you can do this
obviously in the 2d floor plan
completely up to you we can click and
utilize this offset all edges tool so we
can
make it bigger or smaller on all edges
what we want to do is bring it in to the
inside
press 10 mil click enter and there we go
our cladding has run all the way through
to the bottom of the slab
there are multiple ways of doing this
this is the quickest and easiest way
simply for presentation purposes only
not for construction
so keep that in mind what we want to do
is replicate that exact first floor on
the next floor
and move back to our ground floor plan
we can select
all of these walls again individually or
by pressing one
and clicking alt g because they are
connected
click command c for copy move back to
our first floor plan and click command
v for paste and then it will replicate
all the materials all the parameters
absolutely everything
so we have our first floor okay so we
have our structure
now what needs to happen it needs a roof
simply
going over to the roof tool on the right
hand side
or the roof floor plan sorry and
clicking
roof tool we are able to start designing
our roof
the roof is a very simple tool you can
use it for a single plane
mono pitch or you can use it for a
multi-plane
typical pitched roof for this design we
want to select this
single plane and start by falling it
to the rear so what we can do is click
on the bottom side move it up
and then draw our roof to the external
side
and that roof is created we'll go back
to 3d and we can see
our nice big pitched roof however that's
a little bit too pitch for me in this
design and i want to move it up another
300 or 200 mil whatever it is 270 mil
so what we can do is click command d to
activate the move tool
then you can click on the corner and
move it up where you need to
alternatively by clicking command z we
can undo that
you can click on the corner look for all
these options
and look for the drag tool and then you
can drag it up you can drag absolutely
anywhere
but we need to drag it just there and we
want to reduce the pitch of that
we can do that multiple ways we can
reduce it here or we can reduce it
by going back to the roof plan and
clicking
the settings tab or command t
so for the purposes of this we'll do it
in 3d we want to reduce that to
5 degrees just a small little pitch and
then what we want to do again is select
all those walls
ungroup them by pressing alt g drag up
to pass that roof click on the roof as
well
right click and then go connect
trim elements to roof and shell and
trim so now our roof has been perfectly
trimmed
and we don't need to worry about cutting
and moving all those walls individually
let's move back to the floor plan and go
to the ground floor plan for the
purposes we're not going to design the
interior so much we're just going to add
few doors windows and walls
so if we go back to the wall tool walls
external
we're drawing some internal walls
they're probably going to be
75 mil stud just to change it up a bit
and we can draw a couple walls
however we want basic we don't really
need to be worrying about it
however what we do want to worry about
is the windows and the doors the
elevation and the look and feel of this
building
so what we're going to do is start by
using the door tool opening up the door
settings
dragging it to the right page and
searching for
door we know what we're looking for
we're looking for a standard door
archicad gives you a whole bunch of
options that you can choose from
but for the purposes of this we'll start
with archicad door 24.
moving back up to the very first
page and selecting this front view to be
able to
view the door what we want to do is
click through
and change everything how we'd like it
to be you can change it however you want
it's completely up to you the only thing
i'm going to be really changing in this
video
is the materials so we're going to come
back to material attributes
scroll down and start changing these
elements
we don't want it to be white we want it
to be
black so what we're going to do is just
go back down change it to monument
it automatically changes everything
quickly and you can just click ok
so let's start putting a couple doors in
we'll put one here
we'll put one here and we'll put one
here let's say we also needed a garage
door we can click back on this
door 24 and look for
our garage door so we have a garage door
24
with the same options as before so we're
just going to
quickly click through to find what we're
looking for
in this case we're looking to change the
materials again so it's in
model attributes we click uniform door
surfaces
and we're going to paint this black as
well
it's going to be a really nice black
house because that's trending at the
moment
and then all of a sudden you click again
and you have two
barn doors so if we were to look at our
floor plan
there we go we're starting to get a
little bit of a building coming together
if we go back to the ground floor plan
we can activate the window tool
come back to the window setting again
drag it across
and select the type of windows we want
so we'll just use fixed windows for the
purposes of argument
we'll make this one three meters long by
800 high which makes it a long
narrow skinny window click ok
and place a couple windows into the
project so there's one
there's two there's three
we're going to change the windows up a
little bit we're going to do the exact
opposite
go 800 by
2 8 with a 200
seal height the seal height is how far
it sits off the slab
so we can easily adjust that whenever we
need one
two
three now if we go back to our 3d view
we can see all the placement of the
doors
the windows and everything now
personally i don't like how this looks
so i can easily adjust it in 3d let's
say we want this door to be
2 8 high to match our windows we want
this window to actually sit higher so we
click
click the little drag vertically button
and click that
we can multiply that very simply by
holding the alt command
pressing on the door and then holding
control and alt
and clicking on the door to replicate
all the parameters of that door we can
do the same with the window
so alt control and alt and it is
repeated
it will memorize the last command you
did so if you
want to do it multiple times you can now
for the purposes of this
we're just running through this quickly
let's drop
all of these windows to
zero seal height so they're all
perfectly aligned now
there we go that's nice they all start
to align it's starting to look a bit
more like an actual building
it's starting to look a lot better what
we want to continue doing is adding some
more windows so let's go back to the
window tool
and maybe we want to do something a bit
quirky let's say we want a nice
big round window so we scroll
through the windows and we've found our
round window 24
let's say we want to make that massive 2
meters
seal height oh let's say 400 mil
it might be the wrong height but we'll
quickly find out we'll click through
everything to find those model
attributes so we can change our window
click on that go back to midnight black
where is our monument there we go click
ok
and insert this giant circle window
now that might be horrendous we're about
to find out actually
not overly half bad but i still don't
like how big that is it needs to be
bigger
so we can quickly edit that up here
there we go
and then we can also click there drop it
down
100 mil so now we have a massive
beautiful window
that is connected into this design now
we've got
doors and windows but only on the first
floor
so we want to come back to the side
panel click on the first floor
and then start putting in some nice
windows up above
let's say we want a beautiful long
narrow window across
the whole design okay so we want to move
back down to our ground
floor hold alt on one of the windows
that we like
and then move back up to our first floor
so it replicates
those settings and we can click it now
let's say we want to corner window
let's move this across open up the
settings by pressing command t
again and going through the settings
until we find
the corner and opening setting you can
easily click on this
look through this list and find exactly
what you're looking for
so for us today it'll be custom corner
custom corner 1 90 degrees simple click
ok
and i've done the wrong side so what we
can do is click control
m to mirror it click on the center and
it'll automatically flip that window
around
so we go by pressing ctrl d moving that
across
and we have a beautiful corner window by
holding down the alt key and clicking
again we can replicate that window
and move it into place as we want it to
be
so if you can't select the window that
you're struggling to find you can tap
through items
until you find exactly what you're
looking for now apologies i am going
extremely quick i'm trying to get this
in 15 minutes and give you as much
information as possible i think i'm well
over time already
but we'll cut this down and make it
super informative
going back to the 3d view now we have
our beautiful highlight window that's a
little bit too high for my
liking let's say we only want that a
meter off the ground so we're changing
that seal height
up here and creating that corner window
let's say we want this corner window to
extend so we
click on the window first we click on
the black hot spot
and we drag that window out in line with
this
it'll automatically snap and let go now
we have this
beautiful long single pane window which
would cost a small fortune but that's
okay
we want to do the same on this side move
this across
and end it in line with that window
there so we have some symmetry
to keep this relatively uniform i don't
think i need too many more windows on
this side i think that's starting to
look a little bit quirky a little bit
fun
terrible design but we're doing this
just to demonstrate
all the features of archicad 24 as
quickly as we can
it's missing some architectural flair
now so what we can do is actually create
some unique
shapes if we go back to roof we can
extend the roof
another 600 or so
by going offset edge maybe let's go
three meters to give it some sort of
awning
if we go back to our design we can see
that roof has extended
three meters over if we go back to our
ground floor plan now
we can actually we can
show trace reference of the roof so we
know exactly how far it extends
alt over our wall and draw a new wall
across
here now we've extended that wall it's
only on the ground floor plan
but we'll need it to extend to the top
so we click the black hot spot
adjust the height and run it to the top
now for the purposes of this i want to
command t and give that internal a
little bit of a timber feel because
well at the moment it's a bit boring so
let's just go floorboards one
for materiality's sake and i want to
replicate that
on the roof here so we're going to go to
the roof plan
show trace reference of the ground floor
plan and you'll notice that you can't
see anything
that's because the roof has a fill on it
so we want to come over to our trace
reference
and click that last icon to give it an
x-ray view
now we can still click on our roof we
can come up to the top and select this
axe or we can press control forward
slash
and then all we want to do is run one
click
run the axe pass the wall second click
and cut in the direction we want to keep
the plane
we're going to fix this roof up by going
command t painting the inside with that
same
floorboard one
and now we have this floorboard wrap
around look
if we wanted to get even more quirkier
with this design and say we wanted to
cut this wall
all the way up at a nice degree you can
do that multiple ways but i think the
easiest way for me personally is by
using the roof tool
so by using the roof tool we're going to
start here drag it across
and create just another small roof panel
that is going to seem odd at the start
but it'll all make sense in a second so
we've created this roof tool
and we're going to drag it to the ground
floor footings
it isn't at the right angle for me there
we go so 67
is probably the perfect amount okay so
the easiest way to actually
emulate this wall and what we're looking
for is by starting the clicking on the
wall
then moving up to design and falling
down to solid
element operations moving our new panel
across into the window that's being
recorded
we're clicking on our roof secondly and
adding as the operator
the operator is the one that is cutting
and doing the work
we want to subtract with a downwards
extrusion we don't want to delete
this bit we want to delete this bit
which is below hence the downwards
and then all we have to do is click
execute and it will
delete that section of the wall we want
to make this invisible
so what we're going to do is open up the
settings panel again
change that to only one millimeter thick
and
make that a new element which is just
air so if we click on that change those
settings
you can see that we have to one adjust
that
and to readjust the height
but now we have a hidden element that
won't be seen in 3d
and gives you a perfectly cut section
now i have an additional plug-in to my
archicad 24 which you may or may not
have
if you don't have it that's okay you
don't need it for the purpose of this
video
you can simply click these two roof
elements
and change it to material steel
same as we did for the walls so it's the
roof corrugated sheet metal that we're
looking for
and clicking okay so it will give you
the same
appearance all around which isn't
perfect but you can also
change the sides to give you that roof
sheet metal
alternatively if you do have a plug-in
we can go to ci tools we can go to
coverings and we can go to roof covering
drag that panel across again changing
that
to a corrugated look with some gutters
and clicking ok what you will notice is
because we cut the roof we have this
join panel so we want to click
these two elements go back to ci tools
coverings
edit roof edges we don't need anything
here so we're going to click on that
line and go
none and this is not a junction it is a
barge so we're going to change that to
barge
and we click ok so you see it removes
that and adds an element to the rear
side of this roof
we have a gutter on this side so
theoretically we're going to have down
pipes coming in
but we're not going to draw them in for
this video all this purple is giving me
a headache so we're going to go back
into the
tools change that purple to black and if
that doesn't do the trick you can always
overwrite the object pen and change it
to black
so if we update that there we go
that element is completely gone we are
safe
unfortunately we have messed this up so
we need to quickly change that
back to floorboards brown
and we have our house completed now
we're going to take this over into twin
motion
and start rendering it properly so make
sure you install twin motion all the
plugins so you can do this properly
that'll be a completely different video
or i'm sure you can search it
on youtube right now but what you want
to do is go to twin motion 2020 and
direct link and there we go so we say
it's a new project and we click ok
it'll synchronize it it'll make it and
it'll look horrendous
so what we actually want to do is start
putting some materials some textures and
making this look nice
now it's a different control mechanism
for a twin motion as it is on archicad
but it's similar to that explore mode
so by clicking on this floor plate we
can drag that up
to just hide the bottom of that but
because our door is so much higher we're
going to keep dragging it
to the bottom of the door we're going to
open up the side panel go to materials
ground nature grass to drag
drop and for argument we're just going
to drag it up
to 3 scale and there we go
now it's looking a little bit odd it's
looking a little bit funny but we can go
back to our library
into our materials metal drag
that down until we find the nice metal
that we're looking for
aluminium sliding is perfect that's what
we're looking for we want it black so we
click on the color
we drag it down to where we think black
looks good in the settings i think
personally that looks good so we're
going to click and use
that now we go we can click the little
eyedropper
and select the archicad materials which
is
metal aluminium now if we want to
replicate the colors we click back on
that sliding material that we just
selected click on the color
double click on the hashtag color number
copy that across go back click on our
windows again
click on the color and paste that number
in so all those
colors are identical they don't look
identical
so what we're actually going to do is
copy the monument black
and use that there
now there isn't too much on this project
so we're going to change the glass to
reflective
which is perfect we're going to change
that wood look because it doesn't look
nice to this dark
timber and we're going to change the
rotation
90 degrees so if you missed that it was
just in more on scale
again very quick tutorial i hope you're
keeping up so if we come back out
we have this stunning home that is
looking very odd in
its settings so we want to change that
up a little bit when i click down here
to the settings
the location allows us to change the
date and time and the actual location
so if we move that down just before
sunset somewhere about
oh there's looking quite nice personally
speaking we're going to go back to
settings change the weather
add some clouds beautiful back to
location and the background
so it looks a little bit odd let's put
it in a mountain view okay so we have
our building that's almost ready to
export if we come up we're going to just
quickly add some trees
so for me personally it's just come into
the trees
go to the tree section click on one tree
once
let's give ourselves some room and we're
only going to take one image so we're
just going to click like crazy to create
some trees and some forestry
okay so that's all the trees i'm going
to add then i'm going to add a few
little shrubs here and there
just to give that bush forest look we're
going to
click as many as we can we might need to
add some more later on but we'll find
out there is an alternative method to
doing this which is a lot quicker and
easier
but i like the control and the
consistency if you want to do it a
different method
you can click down here go vegetation
paint
and select whatever tree or whatever
shrub you want to paint so we use that
base bush
click there click the paint button
and just draw lots and lots and lots
without having to click a million times
you also have that option but again i
like the clicking i like satisfaction
and there we go we're ready to export
our image all we have to do is click
media image create first image
now it's automatically shifted that out
so we want to go to camera
sorry we want to go to more and then
camera settings
and start bringing that in a little bit
maybe about
75 we don't want depth of field we don't
want that
we don't want that and then we're going
to go back to our image
readjust our positioning there refresh
and recapture
and we're going to go export image click
on the one image
and click start export for arguments
we'll just
select the desktop and let it export
export is relatively quick for one image
take a couple seconds but we'll let it
do its thing and there you have it guys
that render is exported it's done it's
perfect for that first
consultation that project hopefully took
only about 15 minutes but looking at my
timer
we're well over 40 minutes so i'm going
to try to condense this as much as i can
and hopefully it provided some you some
value anyway that's all for me today
guys thanks so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video i hope you got
some information out of it
if you did again i apologize for the
speed make sure you smash that subscribe
button down below
today's video is part of my 28 videos in
28 days series
so it's usually i'll see you next monday
but because we are still in february
i will see you tomorrow